und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka guten
abend schon wieder ein fleisch betrieb
als corona hotspot diesmal bei der firma
tönnies einem der deutschen
branchenriesen und es sind so viele
mitarbeiter betroffen auch solche mit
kindern des im gesamten kreis gütersloh
alle schulen und kitas geschlossen
wurden von rund 1000 getesteten
mitarbeitern sind mindestens 650 corona
positiv das ist allerdings heftig
offenbar wird in fleisch betrieben das
virus besonders schnell verbreitet
andere industrien sind nicht so
auffällig dafür muss es gründe geben
welche konsequenzen werden daraus
gezogen das frage ich gleich den
nordrhein westfälischen
gesundheitsminister doch zunächst
berichtet thomas mit noch im mai hatte
clemens tönnies geradezu verärgert
reagiert als es hieß dass die
fleischindustrie in deutschland künftig
ohne billigarbeiter mit werkverträgen
auskommen soll
einige schwarze schafe würden den ruf
der schlachthöfe verzerren und die
politik handele falsch also zuallererst
würde ich mal erwarten dass man sich an
den tisch setzt und nicht drauf haut das
populistischen stück weit wir wollen das
produkt fleisch wir haben der auch den
versorgungsauftrag an den halten bei uns
für eine sichere versorgung ja und die
müssen wir aufrechterhalten
nun hat es auch seinen betrieb erwischt
im rheder sind 657 von 983 getesteten
osteuropäischen arbeitern mit
werkverträgen positiv der betrieb in dem
sonst wohnt täglich 46 1000 schweine
geschlachtet werden wurde umgehend
geschlossen für mindestens zehn tage
steht alles still
der fall turniers zeigt ganz klar es
handelt sich in dieser branche eben
gerade nicht nur um einzelne schwarze
schafe sondern eher um eine ganze herde
schwarzer schafe jetzt hat es den
marktführer erwischt wir haben
eigentlich nur darauf gewartet denn es
hat sich sehr wenig getan
im unterkünften wie diesen wohnen auch
die turniers mitarbeiter unter deutlich
bemängelten hygienischen bedingungen mit
den allgemeinen lockerungen habe der
aufbruch deshalb nichts zu tun sagt der
ministerpräsident sagt darüber überhaupt
nichts aus weil roman
bulgarien angereist sind unter der virus
herkommt das wird überall passieren
in ganz deutschland ähnliche regelungen
wehrmann spargelhof in bayern von paar
wochen gehabt wir haben den fall im
coesfeld gehabt das hat nichts mit
lockerungen zu tun sondern mit der
unterbringung von menschen in
unterkünften und arbeitsbedingungen in
betrieben oder die folgen der wohl nicht
beherrschbaren risiken müssen nun die
schüler und kinder im kreis ausbaden
sämtliche schulen und kitas wurden
wieder geschlossen verständnis dafür
dass eltern der sauer sind ist es dass
gerade erst angelaufen das ist immer
noch ein milderes mittel als zu sagen
wir haben hier ein shutdown im kreis
gütersloh dass wir auch noch mal wichtig
zu betonen
ob weitere maßnahmen nötig sind wird
entschieden wenn alle testergebnisse
vorliegen
die insgesamt rund 7.000 turniers
mitarbeiter in rheda wiedenbrück wurden
unter häusliche quarantäne gestellt und
zuständig für arbeit und gesundheit der
nordrhein westfalen ist der minister
karl josef laumann von der cdu guten
abend herr laumann ist haben wir vor
wenigen wochen gesagt die lage die
korona lage nordrhein westfalen ist
beherrschbar aber für fleisch betriebes
scheint das nicht zu gelten oder nein
wir haben ja mit dem fall az rheda
wiedenbrück wieder einen wirklich großen
ausbruch werden von 1000 testen mehr als
zwei drittel positiv sind dann ist das
schon eine alarmsituation und deswegen
ist ja auch richtig dass wir heute
gesagt haben wir schließen den
schlachthof dass wir entschieden haben
dass die menschen in quarantäne gehen
müssen 7000 menschen die auf diesen
schlachtruf arbeiten unabhängig von der
frage ob sie werkvertrags arbeitnehmer
sind oder nicht dass wir alle
schlachtung mitarbeiter nicht nur in
rheda wiedenbrück sondern auch im ganzen
ort in nordrhein westfalen noch einmal
wieder testen das haben wir ja vor
einigen wochen schon mal eher gemacht
wir müssen jetzt einfach alles daran
setzen dass diese infektionen auf dem
lokalen bereich des schlachthofes
begrenzt bleiben dass das virus nicht
überspringt in andere gesellschaftliche
gruppen
die wird natürlich auch dafür sorgen
dass so viele menschen auch gut versorgt
sind auch medizinisch gut versorgt sind
aber wir setzen zurzeit alles daran dass
es ein lokaler ausbruch bleibt und dass
nur hermann das ist ja nicht die
strategie das ist ja nicht der erste
ausbruch also man muss doch auch
irgendwann konsequenzen daraus ziehen
dass offenbar im fleisch betrieben sich
dieses virus enorm ausbreitet und das
offi zu spät erst festgestellt wird
jetzt schon 560 leute die sich infiziert
haben das ist ja nicht alles an einem
tag passiert also was für konsequenzen
werden gezogen wenn jetzt in zwei wochen
die quarantäne vorbei ist wird der
betrieb dann einfach wieder aufgemacht
und alles läuft so wie vorher oder sowie
der schlachthof hat natürlich jene
konzepte sie wissen ein schlachthof hat
immer sehr sehr lang sein
es geht auch um die frage wie sind die
menschen untergebracht
ich kann ihnen nur sagen mit mir haben
sie ja ein politiker der schon seit
vielen vielen jahren immer wieder sagt
wir können das so auf den schlachthöfen
nicht weitermachen kein land hat so
stark wie nordrhein-westfalen in den
letzten monaten auch schon im letzten
jahr die schlachthöfe kontrolliert und
es ist ja nach dem ausbruch in coesfeld
und der dann ja auch noch in einigen
schlachthöfen in niedersachsen war vom
bundeskabinett veränderungen für die
schlacht hilfe beschlossen worden dass
wir eben als arbeitsschutz mehr rechte
bekommen dass wir auch mehr die
wohnsituation uns anschauen können und
natürlich auch bis hin zu der frage dass
die besitzer von schlachthöfen auch eine
verantwortung dafür haben müssen wie die
menschen die ja oft aus anderen ländern
kommen die dort arbeiten letzten endes
untergebracht sind und das hat auch
etwas damit zu tun dass man aus meiner
sicht das kerngeschäft eines
schlachthofes nämlich tiere zu
schlachten und zerlegen nicht einfach
nur über werksverträge auslösen kann wie
es ja bei uns sind da ist alles jetzt
war es nämlich lange versagt
der bundestag soll diese gesetz bitte
mal in einen eil durchgang beschließen
damit wir andere verhältnisse bekommen
und die gesetze beziehen sich auf eine
arbeitsrechtliche fragen also zum
beispiel ob solche werkverträge
überhaupt noch gestaltet sind aber jetzt
bis dahin das wird bis ende des jahres
dauern braucht man doch erstmal konzepte
damit dieser zone ausbrüche in dieser
schlacht dürfen nicht ständig
stattfinden was ist da geplant dass wir
noch die hälfte der belegschaft daran
darf dass man weniger kühlt das scheint
ja auch eine rolle bei diesem virus zu
spielen dass kälte mag oder dass alle
getestet werden bevor sie überhaupt in
den betrieb reinen dürfen nach längerer
abwesenheit was genau konkret passiert
jetzt also es ist so dass natürlich
jedes schlachthof ein hygiene konzept
hat
und dieses konzept wird auch die
behörden vorgelegt wir machen sie
nordrhein westfalen so auch das haben
wir noch vor wenigen tagen auch uns noch
mal mit den arbeitsschutz angeguckt
zurzeit kann die man sagen wie ist
dieses virus in die finger bekommen hat
es wird den arbeitsbedingungen zu tun
hat es mit fragen die sie angesprochen
haben mit den klimaverhältnissen ein
schlachthof zu tun in der zerlegung zu
tun
oder hat es mit der wohnsituation zu tun
oder ist es wieder das unternehmen
zurzeit ja teilweise sagt hängt es damit
zusammen dass die leute in ihren
heimatländern war nur um letztes mal zu
sagen wir haben durch das lka eine
aufhebung von risikogebieten in europa
außer den ländern wo die allermeisten
werkvertrags aber nehmen wir kommen ist
das infektionsrisiko zurzeit wenn sie
sich die zahlen anschauen auch nicht
höher wie bei uns in nordrhein westfalen
sicherlich kann man so einen ausbruch
nie ganz ausschließen da wo ganz viele
menschen zusammen arbeiten immerhin 7000
menschen in einer firma aber ich bin
ganz sicher dass es auch mit den wohn
und arbeitsbedingungen die in der
fleischwirtschaft für viele menschen
nicht optimal gestaltet sind zu tun hat
sie sprachen deswegen muss es hier auch
gesetzliche veränderungen geben dass
diejenigen die schlachthöfe gehören auch
eine verantwortung habe für die menschen
die dort aber sie sprachen es ja auch
gerade an die meisten arbeiter kommen
aus rumänien oder bulgarien die bei
subunternehmen januar angestellt sind
hat ministerpräsident laschet heute
gesagt naja wenn die das virus zu uns
bringen
da können wir ja quasi nichts für also
abgesehen davon dass wir diese leute
dahin holen damit sie eine unglaublich
schlecht bezahlter harte arbeit machen
erklärt das aber doch immer noch nicht
selbst wenn ein bulgare
dieses virus einschleppt warum auf einen
schlag 600 leute sich in seiner firma
anstecken das passiert auch in anderen
industrien der form auch nicht
also wir haben solche entwicklungen wie
die sie auf schlachtet man habe mit
keiner anderen industrie zumindest in
deutschland gehabt und das macht auch
deutlich dass die bedingungen die wir
zurzeit in deutschland schlachthöfe
betreiben so nicht bleiben können nur
das kann ich ich würde mich gar nicht
entschuldigen mit landesgesetzgeber und
nicht ändern
dafür brauchen wir den bundesgesetzgeber
es sind in den letzten
die dann immer wieder gesetze gemacht
worden für die schlachthöfe ein
besonderes arbeitsrecht energie fleisch
aber man muss auch sagen schachtel für
waren oft auch so finde ich dass man das
alles umgangen ist und damit muss
schlicht und ergreifend schluss sein
zum schluss wird nur sein wenn
diejenigen die schlachthöfe in diesem
land gehören eine general haftung auch
haben
für diejenigen die man wert vertrags
arbeitnehmer nicht am anfang geht für
das gespräch danke schön dass inter wir
haben wir aufgezeichnet ein hinweis
norris sind 650 positiv getestete nicht
560 statischen zahlendreher
und wir hatten ein technisches
tonproblemen herr laumann konnte mich
teils erst mit einiger verzögerung
verloren die fleisch betriebe sind
zweifellos das größte problem aber auch
andernorts läuft nicht alles so wie
erhofft die westdeutsche allgemeine
zeitung berichtet dass es allein in nrw
bereits an elf grundschulen corona
vergibt eine grundschule in wuppertal
musste direkt wieder schließen
kaum war sie am montag in den
regelbetrieb gegangen ein schüler wurde
positiv getestet jetzt sind alle in
quarantäne ganz passt das nicht zu der
aussage der nordrhein-westfälischen
schulministerin die der bevölkerung
versichert hatte bei kindern unter zehn
jahren gäbe es praktisch kein
infektionsrisiko über schulen im
besonderen und corona im allgemeinen
wurde heute natürlich auch beim treffen
der ministerpräsidenten mit angela
merkel gesprochen
erstmals seit märz hatte sie alle wieder
leibhaftig bei sich im kanzleramt aus
berlin nicole diekmann es hakt noch ein
bisschen besonders bei den
brillenträgern unter dem
ministerpräsidenten auf ihren vorherigen
gemeinsamen konferenzen brauchten sie
noch keine masken
denn die fanden per videoschalte stadt
jetzt also lockerungen auch hier jedoch
weiter mit aller vorsicht nach dem
treffen der mps mit der kanzlerin fast
zusammen viel lockerer wird es auch
erstmal nicht
es bleibt dabei dass bürgerinnen und
bürger weiter grundsätzlich ein
mindestabstand von 1 5 meter einzuhalten
haben und dass diese maßnahme ergänzt
wird durch eine mund nasen bedeckung in
bestimmten öffentlichen bereichen
verstärkte hygienemaßnahmen und das
instrument der kontakt
beschränkungen ramme ist voller oktober
festzelte sorglose stunden in
menschenmassen
diese zeiten sind weiterhin erstmal
vorbei großveranstaltungen bleiben bis
mindestens ende oktober verboten
ausnahmen sollen zwar möglich sein wenn
hygiene und abstandsregeln eingehalten
werden
das wird dann allerdings ganz bestimmt
anders aussehen als so schulen und kitas
aber sollen nach den sommerferien wieder
in die alte normalität zurückkehren
die test kapazitäten bis dahin wieder
ausgeweitet werden
auf all das habe man sich sehr
gemeinschaftlich geeinigt wurde heute
auffallend oft betont ja auch noch meine
einschätzung war es heute sehr viel
einfacher dass wir uns auf die
gemeinsamen fragen zum infektionsschutz
noch einmal verständigen
inhaltliches gruppenkuscheln in zeiten
der pandemie
ganz so war es dann doch nicht einen
seitenhieb auf seinen potenziellen
widersacher im rennen um die
kanzlerkandidatur könnte sich der csu
chef auch heute wieder nicht verkneifen
das hat langsam tradition krone ist wie
ein funke der mitten ein neues buch
feuer auslösen könne
anders sieht es in einzelfällen gestern
die der herr in nordrhein westfalen die
gütersloh und den gütersloh der
fleischereibetrieb tönnies der neue
corona infektionsherd mitten im
bundesland das armin laschet regiert der
will von einem duell mit söder nichts
hören und auch nichts von den schlechten
nachrichten aus der heimat wie in den
letzten tagen sehr harmonisch wir haben
ja fast die gleichen regelungen reuse
nur in unterschiedlichen zeitfolge
überall sinken die infektionen
nordrhein-westfalen hat heute 70 prozent
weniger als zum beginn der lockerungen
und das zeigt der weg den wir gegangen
sind es richtig aber die haben ja auch
ungefähr dieselben ambitionen
nein dann soll es schnell gehen schnell
weg von den unangenehmen fragen unterm
strich lief es heute harmonisch in
berlin wenn auch nicht zwischen 1
es hakt ein bisschen den sachen corona
virus gibt es aber auch hoffnungsvolle
nachrichten heißt das tübinger
unternehmen turek darf jetzt einen
möglichen impfstoff an gesunden
freiwilligen testen die genehmigung
dafür sei erteilt hieß es vom
zuständigen paul-ehrlich-institut erste
ergebnisse ob der impfstoff wirkt und
verträglich ist könnte es ab september
geben zulassungen dann frühestens anfang
nächsten jahres
jurek ist neben ballack die zweite
deutsche firma die ihren impfstoff
klinisch testen darf in china wächst die
sorge vor einer zweiten corona welle vor
allem in der hauptstadt peking
dort sind seit vergangener woche 137
neuinfektionen registriert worden
nachdem zuvor in der stadt praktisch
keine übertragungen mehr gemeldet worden
waren
ein großer markt wurde geschlossen fast
30 wohnviertel wurden unter quarantäne
gestellt heute vor 67 jahren sind etwa
eine million menschen in der ddr auf die
straße gegangen kampf für mehr freiheit
und freie wahlen
der volksaufstand vom 17 juni 1953 war
die erste große protestbewegung in rund
700 städten und gemeinden um der opfer
zu gedenken wurden in mehreren
bundesländern kränze niedergelegt
der volksaufstand wurde damals vom
sowjetischen militär blutig
niedergeschlagen dabei starben mehr als
50 menschen und haft kamen mehr als
10.000 der kindesmissbrauchs fall
münster nimmt noch größere ausmaße an
wie der nordrhein-westfälische
innenminister rolle im innenausschuss
des landtags mitteilte gebe es
inzwischen 18 verdächtige und sechs
identifizierte opfer im kindesalter
sieben verdächtige seien nach wie vor in
untersuchungshaft
der fall war erst anfang dieses monats
öffentlich geworden zunächst waren drei
opfer im alter zwischen fünf und zwölf
jahren ermittelt worden
der deutsche buchhandel zeichnet den
ökonomen matthias senn mit dem
friedenspreis 2020 aus er sei ein
vordenker in fragen der globalen
gerechtigkeit und seine arbeiten seien
so relevant wie nie zuvor so die
begründung der preis ist mit 25.000 euro
dotiert
der 86-jährige ist auch philosoph unter
ist wirtschaftsnobelpreisträger amartya
sen ist in seiner kindheit in indien in
einer hungersnot aufgewachsen und lehrte
später an renommierten instituten in den
usa wo er bis heute lebt
man muss nicht auf andere länder zeigen
um rassismus zu finden den gibt es bei
uns ganz genau so und es gibt ihn auch
in brüssel europas hauptstadt die sich
doch eigentlich als so weltoffen und
international versteht als die deutsche
europaabgeordnete pierre et herzberger
fofana heute berichtete was ihr am tag
zuvor am busbahnhof widerfahren war
wurde es still im europäischen parlament
ein parlament übrigens in dem die 71
jährige abgeordnete von
sicherheitsleuten immer mal wieder
gefragt wird was sie wird eigentlich zu
suchen hatte anne gellinek berichtet es
ist herrlich der tag halb zwei mittags
als pirat herzberger fofana am
nordbahnhof aussteigt eine finstere ecke
brüssels prostitution gestrandeten
migranten viel polizei herzberger
beobachtet eine gruppe polizisten die
zwei schwarze jugendliche bedrängen und
macht ein foto das wird ihr zum
verhängnis die polizisten gehen auf sie
los vier beamte schreien sie annehmen
ihr das handy ab durchsuchen sie die
haben mir einfach gesagt ich soll jetzt
sagen die wand gehen und so weiter ich
habe mich geweigert und dann haben mich
diese politischen da und die wand
gedrückt und ich sollte die beine
aufmachen
also das war ein bissiger war sehr
demütigend für mich das herzberger
fofana eine deutsche europaabgeordnete
der grünen ist glauben sie
nicht ein beamter fragt ob sie
vielleicht im parlament putzen
erst als ihr fahrer kommt ein weißer
lassen sie von ihr ab sie hätte nie
gedacht dass ihr so etwas passieren
könnte sagt herzberger am tag danach 15
jahre lang saß sie im stadtrat von
erlangen seit einem jahr nun im
europaparlament nie hatte sie angst
ausgerechnet heute ist eine rassismus
debatte angesetzt mit schweigeminute für
george floyd herzberger erzählt im
parlament was ihr widerfuhr flagship
store review parlement ich bin heute
hier obwohl ich die ganze nacht im
parlament verbracht habe weil ich mich
nicht mehr auf die straße raus getraut
habe bis heute morgen umsetzen
wir müssen etwas tun für die die heute
nicht hier sind und die sich nicht gegen
polizeigewalt wehren können die stimmung
in belgien ist seit wochen aufgeheizt
die debatte über rassismus und
polizeigewalt verschränkt sich mit einer
über die grausame koloniale
vergangenheit des landes auch in brüssel
trifft man sich nachts zum denkmalsturz
wieder kippt ein standbild des
belgischen königs leopold des zweiten
vom sockel
rassismus ist ein koloniales erbe
er klebt an unserer gesellschaft seine
gewalt steckt in straßennamen und den
statuen die unsere plätze ziere leopold
gehöre ins museum sagen sie da steht er
auch bewusst ganz in der ecke im gerade
wieder eröffneten afrika museum am
brüsseler stadtrand wird erzählt wie der
belgische könig ende des neunzehnten
jahrhundert den kongo ausbeutet und
welche gräueltaten seine kolonialherren
an den menschen verübten wirklich
aufgearbeitet ist dieser teil der
belgischen geschichte nicht pirat
herzberger fofana jedenfalls will den
vorfall nicht auf sich beruhen lassen
sie hat klage eingereicht wegen
körperverletzung erniedrigen der
behandlung und amtsmissbrauchs die
belgische polizei bislang keinen grund
sich zu entschuldigen und wir schauen
noch mal auf das corona thema beim blick
in die welt wird sich so mancher
bundesbürger in den letzten wochen schon
gesagt haben dass deutschland in dieser
pandemie nicht der schlechteste
aufenthalts
es gibt viele andere länder mit denen
man in diesen zeiten lieber nicht
tauschen möchte großbritannien die usa
russland brasilien einige beispiele bei
denen sich auch zeigt dass ein virus
gegen populismus übrigens immun ist man
kann sich nicht schönreden
und es lässt sich auch nicht von starken
sprüchen beeindrucken
hinzu kommt allerdings dass in ländern
mit riesiger bevölkerung und extreme
armut wie etwa brasilien oder indien
das umsetzen von hygiene und
abstandsregeln auch wirklich um ein
vielfaches schwieriger ist in indien ist
die lage inzwischen so bedenklich dass
die deutsche botschaft allen
bundesbürgern empfiehlt das land zu
verlassen
nach oben zeigt berichtet die leuchten
als packen die koffer das abenteuer
indien ist zu ende
die letzten wochen waren nicht mehr
unbeschwert die korona krise überlagert
einfach alles lockert indiens locker
delhi aber die die fallzahlen steigen
erst recht ja und das ist natürlich sehr
verwirrend das macht angst
wolfgang leuschner kam als pfarrer
hierher vor zehn monaten er weiß was
seine gemeinde seine landsleute umtreibt
die deutschen machen sich große sorgen
wenn sie krank werden was sollen sie
dann tun wenn keine krankenhaus plätze
mehr frei sind oder die so
schwindelerregend teuer sind die betten
preise dass man sich überlegt was ist da
los
deshalb empfiehlt auch die botschaft
jetzt wenn es irgendwie möglich ist
auszureißen
denn die lage spitzt sich zu fast jeder
tag bringt neue rekorde traurige rekorde
mehr infizierte mehr tote meer leid
seit dem frühen morgen fährt rakesh
durch delhi von einem krankenhaus zum
nächsten staatlichen und privaten im
auto sitzt seine kranke tante ob es das
virus ist wissen sie nicht aber es geht
ihr schlecht und überall werden sie
abgewiesen
die ärzte verscheuchen uns geht weg
rufen sie wir nehmen keinen auf die
regierung erzählt dass tausende betten
in den krankenhäusern bereitstünden
ihr müsst nur hingehen da kümmert man
sich um euch sagen sie aber das ist
alles gelogen
von drinnen keine bilder filmen verboten
um so wilder die gerüchte im ganzen land
von mieser hygiene leichen auf den
fluren gerüchte die dr prasad nicht
bestätigt wohl aber dass es auch für das
personal immer schwieriger wird in allen
städtischen krankenhäusern delhi sind
wir ärzte seit drei monaten ohne gehalt
gegen korona arbeiten wir ohne
unterbrechung ohne urlaub mit vollem
einsatz aber ohne lohn
wir werden streiken aber es ist ein
gebot der menschlichkeit dass wir das
jetzt nicht tun
das ohnehin marode gesundheitssystem ist
am anschlag vielleicht auch schon drüber
und metropolen wie delhi sind die
brennpunkte 500 eisenbahnwaggons stehen
jetzt in der hauptstadt bereit mit 8.000
betten weil alle experten damit rechnen
dass es noch schlimmer kommt als es
schon ist
denn der lock down ist weitgehend
ausgesetzt damit die wirtschaft wieder
wächst
doch was vor allem wächst ist die zahl
der infizierten die zahl der toten
die regierung sagt sie tun alles für uns
aber sie tun nichts gar nichts tun sie
dort brennt eine leiche
meine mutter liegt dort ein feuer das
macht die regierung das ist die wahrheit
da ist die trauer da ist die wut und da
ist eine große angst
indien kann sich nicht befreien von
diesen unheimlichen virus
zurück nach deutschland und hier danach
zu den wirtschaftlichen folgen der krise
wie geht es weiter bei der lufthansa es
gibt dazu neue fragezeichen eine woche
vor der wichtigen hauptversammlung weil
er halla worum geht es da ja darum dass
die staatliche rettung der lufthansa nun
doch scheitern könnte ein großaktionär
lehnt den einstieg des bundes bei der
fluglinie ab und er möchte jetzt
nachverhandeln was finanzminister scholz
aber rigoros ausschließt das ist
verhandelt punkt so sagt es der
finanzminister nun drängt die zeit der
lufthansa geht nach einschätzung des
managements ende des monats das geld aus
unternehmer und milliardär heinz hermann
thiele ist bekannt dafür dass er keinen
streit wenn er seinen willen durchsetzen
will den zulieferer knorr-bremse führte
er mit harter hand
nun ist er bei lufthansa eingestiegen
und mit seinem 15 prozent anteil ein
entscheidender player den rettungsplan
lehnte ab er fürchtet dass sich der
staat zu sehr einmischt vor allem beim
stellenabbau 26.000 arbeitsplätze sind
bei der lufthansa und ihren töchtern
gefährdet kommende woche müssen die
aktionäre das rettungspaket absegnen in
einem dramatischen appell fordert die
fluglinie die aktionäre auf an der
schicksals hauptversammlung teilzunehmen
denn kommt wie bei der lufthansa üblich
weniger als die hälfte zur abstimmung
kantine mit seinen stimmen das paket
ablehnen dann droht die insolvenz mit
potenziell schweren folgen massiven
stellenstreichungen und einschnitten
beim flugbetrieb walhalla
vielen dank zwei nachrichten jetzt auch
in eigener sache
im kommenden jahr könnte der
rundfunkbeitrag steigen die
ministerpräsidenten haben sich geeinigt
dass der monatliche beitrag ab januar um
86 cent angehoben werden soll
auf dann 18 eur 36 die erhöhung kommt
allerdings nur wenn auch noch alle
landtage zustimmen
dazu die vorsitzende der
rundfunkkommission der länder malu
dreyer
wir alle spüren in der korona krise noch
einmal wie wichtig unsere medien sind
und wir sind wirklich froh dass wir das
duale system haben natürlich können
medien nur freien unabhängig berichten
wenn sie eine entsprechende
wirtschaftliche grundlage haben der
rundfunkbeitrag ist seit zehn jahren
nicht erhöht worden und deshalb bin ich
heute sehr froh dass die
ministerpräsidenten einheitlich
entschieden haben dass es zu dieser
beitragserhöhung kommen soll um den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk die
grundlage zu geben die sie braucht um zu
arbeiten
dieses jahr wurde der deutsche
fernsehpreis kroner bedingt ohne große
gala verliehen
drei preise gingen an den zdf mehrteiler
preis der freiheit über die ddr
wendezeit erstmalig wurden gleich
mehrere nachrichtenredaktionen die im
fernsehen breit über corona berichtet
haben mit einem sonderpreis der jury
regiert weitere auszeichnungen wurden
überraschend direkt nach einer sendung
im studio an die preisträger übergeben
wie an marietta slomka die für ihre
politischen interviews geehrt wurde
die heute show im bereich comedy unser
dritter fernsehpreis 2010 2014 2020 da
sorgen die sportfreunde stiller mann nie
drüber machen und harald lesch für sein
wissenschafts format ich fühle mich sehr
geehrt vielen dank und freue mich dass
meine redaktion ich so einen granaten
preis bekommen haben vielen dank toll
toll ein ergebnis aus der
fußball-bundesliga von heute abend
eintracht frankfurt hat zwei zu eins
gegen schalke gewonnen und schon gestern
abend hat sich der fc bayern münchen in
der fußball-bundesliga vorzeitig die
deutsche meisterschaft gesichert
als erster absteiger steht paderborn
fest und heute gab es auch die ersten
entscheidungen bei den frauen jena
steigt ab den titel holte erneute vfl
wolfsburg durch 1 und 2 zu 0 sieg gegen
den sc freiburg
für die fußballerinnen aus wolfsburg ist
es der vierte titel nacheinander
auch bei den frauen waren die dritten
leer gefeiert wurde auf dem rasen ohne
die fans um den fussball auf
europäischer ebene ging es heute bei der
uefa demnach stehen im august in der
champions league und in der europa
league zwei finalturniere an dann im
september spiele der
nationalmannschaften am dritten
september kann es wieder losgehen für
das deutsche team wie geplant in der
nations league mit dem duell gegen
spanien 20 21 dann der eigentliche
höhepunkt die europameisterschaft alle
spielorte wird bestätigt auch baku
bilbao und rom was auch beim deutschen
verband begrüßt wird
ich finde es ein großartiges zeichen des
zusammenhalts sind sehr schwierigen
zeiten dass alle zwölf spieler die
mussten sie auch bestätigen stattfindet
der champions league sieger soll in
einem finalturnier in lissabon ermittelt
werden auch nordrhein westfalen darf
sich freuen
die entscheidung in der euroleague ab
dem viertelfinale feld in gelsenkirchen
düsseldorf duisburg und köln und jetzt
noch die zahlen vom lotto am mittwoch
sie lauten wie immer ohne gewähr
6 13 29 35 38 48 superzahl 3 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto
fdp und im zdf text auf seite 55 7 die
urlaubssaison hat begonnen und die
europäer dürfen auch wieder reisen nur
wie läuft das in corona zeiten mit dem
reisen der frage geht jetzt an pieper
nach die für das auslandsjournal nach
frankreich und italien gefahren ist und
um 0.30 gibt es dann heute plus mit
daniel brücke auf das morgen auch wieder
sehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren zwischen
den tiefs octavia und nadine hat sich
ein kleines wolkenband entwickelt und
das zieht in den nächsten 24 stunden so
gut wie gar nicht weiter nach norden
das bedeutet es gibt kräftige regenfälle
auch heftige gewitter sind dabei und
dieses regenband das dämpft auch die
temperaturen
die liegen deswegen morgen zwischen den
niederlanden und österreich nur so um
die 20 grad oder knapp darunter in
südschweden werden es dagegen 27 grad
und damit ist es dort wärmer als an der
côte d'azur mit 25 grad
bei uns liegen die nacht temperaturen
zwischen 17 und 8 grad und in diesem
streifen vom emsland bis zum alpenrand
da gibt's jetzt am abend und in der
ersten nacht helfen nach kräftige
regenschauer und gewitter im nordosten
ist es dagegen klar und dort ist es
morgen auch am freundlichsten gewitter
müssen sie aber richtung saale und aller
durchaus befürchten und auch von polen
ziehen einige regenschauer ein
und dann geht es dieses kräftige regen
band das bringt also viel regen zwischen
dem emsland und hier dem erzgebirge aber
auch zwischen dem westerwald und der
donau sind doch einige gewitter dabei
wie hier zum beispiel auf der
schwäbischen alb am bodensee aber auch
in oberschwaben am oberrhein am
mittelrhein und an der mosel da wird es
morgen freundlicher und die temperaturen
unter den regenwolken die liegen doch
nur bei 16 bis 20 grad sonst werden
nochmal bis 28 grad erreicht am freitag
schüttet es ergiebig in norddeutschland
und wechselhaft geht's weiter schönen
abend noch